i'm reading this book called after steve
right after steve jobs highly recommend
everybody read just book just came out
it's incredible we're talking about it
before the podcast got started
question for you guys okay so the san
bernardino shooting takes place
when the san bernardino shooting takes
place what was the biggest problem that
apple got into with san bernardino
shooting what happened would they unlock
the phone or not comey and obama went to
apple and said what unlock the damn
phone unlock the damn phone and what did
what did cook do what did tim cook say i
can't do that i can't do that
and then they try to really bully him
and he stood up and he said no
this is a bigger thing than short-term
this is a long-term issue that we got to
address right he says i can't do that
because i'm taking a privacy away from
the individual that's using my software
my phone right i'm not going to do that
they lost it they were going to sue him
all this stuff finally they said don't
worry about it we figured out a few
different way to get it they didn't go
after apple right but till since then
apple's been obviously having a
challenge and then later on trump comes
out trump calls out tim cook non-stop
finally tim cook goes and spends time
with trump and next thing you know uh
people ask trump why is tim cook your
favorite president for a favorite ceo
trump's answer was what because he's the
only one that calls me
tim cook is the only one that calls me
this is a first openly gay ceo that
communicates with trump about
you know challenges they're facing as a
company but here's a question
if
facebook knows
what this guy is texting and messaging
i'm throwing a completely different
curveball here i want to get your
thoughts
if facebook knows those dms and they
know he's communicating should facebook
report those dms to fbi well they have
no problem putting
flags on covet 19 things or censoring
people immediately and reporting
accounts
maybe they do have a role in that what
do you think tom i think they absolutely
have a role i mean if they can shut down
a conservative voice and let's talk
about what it is right you say something
too inflammatory about vaccines or about
this or about aoc
boom you know your account can't even be
suspended take you out but longer but
your tweet can be popped like
immediately immediately which means that
they is that good though is is that the
right position for them to do what they
do that's censorship but they could use
the same
technology
they don't have an army of people just
watching tweets they have technology
that's reading tweets and they can put
that same technology and send a notice
to that law enforcement agency and say
hey there may be something very bad
about to happen here
but but what tim cook would say is
tom
you're now giving the government enough
power to use
free market companies to abuse my
privacy i got very technical here with
you on this the only reason i'm talking
about this with you guys is because as
we're going in this angle of all these
arguments of we should use this and we
should use that
the ripple effect of how it affects
other things like you said something
earlier you said well i'm concerned if
we give the background check or or the
training or whatever they may abuse that
and what if later on somebody a
girlfriend says i think my boyfriend's
gonna do something to me and the cops go
and confiscate the weapons and all that
stuff that can lead to that right same
ripple effect when it comes down to hey
we have access to the dm reported to the
fbi so now you're sitting there saying
oh so facebook is owned by the
government facebook is no longer so
what is the right position in these you
know anything good can be used for bad
on the side of it but fine there's a
fine line it doesn't make me nervous it
does make me nervous do you remember the
guy that we had the facebook what was
the guy that we had facebook uh
steve no no but what was his job he was
a moderator he was a moderator and oh
the whistleblower the whistleblower on
facebook that we interviewed him
so so i said do you ever check uh have
you ever since you have access to
everyone's dms and everyone's messages
have you ever gone and looked to see
what people have said he said i can't
lie to you i have
i said who was it my cousins because i
wanted to see if they were talking [ __ ]
about me right so this guy who's a
moderator was more concerned about yeah
but the point is
you're dealing with the slippery slope
of what to do with this right so
you may find the current solution
because i would bad if i'm
a biden or if i'm any of these guys and
i'm in i'm in the campaign so say the
left all of a sudden comes out and says
this is why the next person they could
vilify here is facebook and instagram
and zuckerberg that's the next villain
because the villain is you could have
done something about it because you got
to blame everybody except for the
administration right do not be surprised
if today tomorrow the next day following
week if all of a sudden somehow somebody
zuck gets caught up in this scandal
or yeah and and one issue
that happens
although it's horrible but it
doesn't it's not like this is an
everyday thing right that impacts the
privacy of
millions of americans
and these things are again it's a small
percentage of when these things happen
and
we're creating legislation surrounding
that that's impacting americans as a
whole um snapchat actually helped
a case it was an underage i think sex
trafficking case where somebody was
texting an underage person and they were
able to alert the fbi there are i think
there are some instances where that's
obviously appropriate but then again
it's that fine line of the privacy of of
people and then who's who's creating
that criteria but we're already doing
that now let's not forget that they use
geolocation geotagging the bank accounts
of all the people at january 6th that
went after all those people right
they're now labeling anybody who posts
the wrong thing on facebook against the
teachers union parents as domestic
terrorists like we're they're already
using these for the wrong reasons right
like it's perfect to work in this fairy
tale world where everybody uses things
for the right if you're already it's all
criteria yeah but if you're already
doing that
if you're already doing that
it's kind of like when paul manafort
when i'm like listen lobbyists are the
problem in america and he says look what
are you gonna do the other guys are
doing it
so if they're already doing that for
that reason then you have to be equal
opportunity and give information for uh
other side as well i would much rather
them not do it at all but if they're
going to do it for one side you got to
be equal on the other side as well so
should they be regulated
from an objective perspective i don't
think so i i honestly don't think but at
the same time
you're a fool you have to be naive to
think that
the government is not reaching out
because think about what the phone calls
gonna sound like do you think what do
you think are the chances of a person
like this existing you ready
hey mark how are you
um i uh i'm with the fbi but i'd like to
have a private conversation with you can
you please open that envelope for me
um yeah sure you open it up do you see
what we have here with you
we have this we have this wheel i know
you're happily married and i know you're
a ceo of a very powerful company and
you're one of the most powerful people
in america but if you don't moving
forward tell us what's going on with
these things this is going to be public
do i make myself clear yeah okay so
here's what i need from you by this time
make sense moving forward when i myself
or somebody from my group contacts you i
need this information from you if you
don't help us i just assume this is
going to be public do i make myself
clear yes thank you so much for your
cooperation do you think that kind of a
conversation has already happened with
mark
zuckerberg you're saying yeah do you
think do you think a meeting like that
has happened like what j edgar hoover
and kennedy's had back in the days like
with the mob with j hoover saying just
so you know this is the information we
have on you do you think that kind of a
conversation has happened
what percentage you think it is five
percent ten percent twenty percent
that's probably a twenty percent i think
it's happened remember we um we have the
opportunity to speak to
and we can say this publicly i think
andrew fastoff yeah he talks about that
they did exactly that it wasn't a
marital affair but they came in and they
did strong arm with his wife's taxes on
a nothing item to get him to move and
that's the way the feds work
yeah so if that's happening you just
have to assume that this is already
taking place and then if you are already
playing that game and your company has
already uh got a as much
negative uh reputation as they do dude
keep telling the
administration what you know about
people that could potentially
prevent the next salvador ramos is the
salvador ramos's last name yes saba
ramos from happening anyways so what
what do you think then what do you think
about this picture remind me what do you
think about the patriot act james
snowden or ed snowden came out and said
the government i'm not with it every key
well that's that's essentially the same
case you're making i know i know i'm
saying but i'm i'm saying don't do it
from the beginning
at all no because because what you're
doing is
you know what you're doing listen
people think we're going to live in la
la land
you're not going to live in la la land
do you know what hillary clinton just
got caught with
hillary if if this even didn't take
place this week you know what everybody
would be talking about the big loss the
big lie of hillary clinton so what is
the big lie of hillary clinton hillary
clinton sitting there quietly
you know voicing her opinion about this
event yet at the same time
um
hillary clinton caught him perhaps the
most shocking lie of her career
uh washington times the head of hillary
clinton's 2016 campaign for the
presidency robbie
mook testified on friday hillary clinton
approved of an effort in the months
before 2016 election to provide the
press with research perpetrating to show
a computer link between the company of
her gop rival donald trump and a russian
bank mook on friday was specified on
behalf of michael sussman a high-powered
democratic lawyer and accuser uh
accused uh clinton lawyer according to
mook he discussed it giving dubious
information to the press with hillary as
well but i believe i discussed it with
her after we kind of discussed it and
made the decision not notionally
the discussion was hey we have this and
we want to share with the reporter she
agreed to it the prosecution claimed
sussman billed the clinton campaign for
this piece of dubious information and
the prosecution claims that it has been
evidence for making this claim so
these guys are doing that non-stop to
the american people worse than watergate
yeah these guys are doing that left and
right and people are sitting around
saying uh
who's getting the who's getting uh
destroyed with this or manipulated with
this the professionals are doing this
non-stop all i'm saying is behind closed
doors
you don't think one of her associates
has had conversations with social media
companies to say hey you better or else
well it's like how they always
threatened the the heads of the ceo
companies to testify in front of
congress
yeah they're always pressuring them you
have to do more you have to stop the
disinformation and i love the fact that
some of them are starting to have a
backbone
i love the fact that bezos is having a
backbone musk is having a backbone some
of them are not pushing back and saying
look
enough with blaming all of us we're sick
and tired of it bro do you realize we
created 450 000 jobs that you haven't
created we created so they don't rely on
the government you keep bashing me here
why don't you go create 450 000 jobs
without taxpayer we're creating this
economy you're not doing it yeah so
it's a very dirty game i was uh uh i was
uh watching a documentary on the way
here
uh of uh do you know what this guy uh
they call him the pharma bro yeah martin
shkreli you remember the pharma bro have
you seen this documentary or no it's
worth checking out by the way pharma pro
i've not seen this yeah i i will tell
you in the tweets and clips very
entertaining so what do they do so this
guy's going out there and a drug that's
cost 13 he's selling you for 7.50
a little bit more than seven this guy's
a certified dirtbag he he is a very very
strange guy right but you know what they
did you know how he went to jail for
seven years not for what he did with the
drug he went to jail for seven years
because a hedge fund used to run years
ago that had nothing to do with this and
he had multiple different companies
where he was just kind of moving the
money over from different places and
taking over money laundering motivation
what was he doing not tax evasion it's
it's multiple corporations where he was
moving the money raising one place and
moving to another company and then he
eventually got caught with that and his
lawyer couldn't win
and uh he got seven years but but the
point just got out though yeah but by
the way he'd be a great guest to have i
mean rob if you're listening to this
let's have him on as a guest that'd be a
great conversation to have with him uh
yeah he got two uh two counts of
securities fraud and one count of
conspiring to commit securities fraud so
sometimes when you get a little too loud
you get that knock musk just got that
knock
i think bezos is afraid of getting that
knock he feels a little brave today but
it's bad when people are afraid
of voicing their opinion to get that
knock
it's a it's a form of censorship and i
know they call it silencing but it's a
form of censorship and you know what's
the biggest freedom with that the fbi
rate on james o'keefe yeah so you go
into this part yeah but so you know
going back to what you're asking yeah
i'm not with it i don't i don't support
that our sweetheart hillary clinton
is the master at it but i don't support
it what was his was his name her
campaign manager a little guy with the
glasses podesta
yeah john podesta yeah remember he
blamed
facebook
for the loss
of course remember but morris coming
remember yeah he did well and by the way
he lost the election he's the campaign
manager so he's going to blame
the moon the tides and the wind and
trump
and comey
but um they directly blamed facebook
and zuckerberg because zuckerberg didn't
cooperate and he was actually trying to
to let both sides out there but there
were a lot of bots that were going on on
facebook but the point was facebook was
actually trying to
and by the way they're not exactly in a
white hat here it's sort of a dark gray
hat
but they did not kowtow to it
and then
you're being blamed publicly and who was
the guy that ended up in the seat in the
hearing
mark yeah remember of course all of them
did all the ceos yeah
all the support that really got
barbecued who really got barbecued mark
right zuckerberg and who got the easy
questions google
correct sundar pinchai but dorsey had to
take a lot of heat
if you go take a look dorsey just uh
resigned from being on the board right
they just a form of almost got fired off
the board
because of defending elon and conda on
the what do you call it the fake uh
fake bots so uh he's so that means now
dorsey and elon are united against the
board which is awesome because they
realize that whatever they do will never
be enough yeah left
never be enough so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]